Anti-cancer immune response can be conceptualized
as a series of stepwise events referred to
as the Cancer-Immunity Cycle.
The cycle include: Step 1, release of cancer
cell antigens; Step 2, cancer antigen presentation;
Step 3, priming and activation; Step 4, trafficking
of immune cells to tumors; Step 5, infiltration
of immune cells into tumors; Step 6, recognition
of cancer cells by T cells; and Step 7, killing
of cancer cells.
In this exercise, we will profile the status
of anti-cancer immunity across seven-step
of Cancer-Immunity Cycle, and infer the proportion
of various tumor-infiltrating immune cells
using the Tracking Tumor Immunophenotype,
or TIP web-based tool.
The TIP is a meta-server which integrates
systematically two existing third party methods
for tracking, analyzing and visualizing the
status of anti-cancer immunity. and the proportion
of tumor-infiltrating immune cells across
seven-step of Cancer-Immunity Cycle using
transcriptomic data.
To start with the immunotype profiling, we
will first need to cleanup the transcriptomic
dataset.
Note, for the dataset to be uploaded to the
TIP, there should be no missing values within
the table, and no duplication of gene ID.
To prepare the dataset, we will first remove
the unnamed gene ID.
Next, we will remove the columns with zero
read count.
And finally, we will remove any duplicated
gene ID.
Once the dataset is cleaned up.
We will save it as a separate TSV file.
Now, we will upload the file onto the TIP
tool.
Once the analysis is done, you can export
the results for further analysis.